what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
Brooklyn Nine-Nine season 4 episode 3
today alrighty well I'm excited for this
ladies and gentlemen hey John how's it
going I'm great how are you doing well
thank you buddy for asking I appreciate
that what a great question to ask of a
time like this
but how are you are you terrible
um so guys please leave a like that'd be
exceptionally appreciated and uh as
always full interaction watch long as we
single with your own copy for b99
available for our super sexy rejects
appreciate the support let's get let's
just do it
the man identified as Gregory Stickney
and Larry Sherbert were arrested after a
routine traffic stop revealed a cache of
automatic weapons less than 12 hours
later the men escaped by creating a
disturbance in their cell while they
started kissing which I'm fine with
really I am kiss whatever you want
except they were both men
[Laughter]
out of jail earlier this evening Greg
Stickney and Larry Sherbert are believed
to be liquid moan nice I wore the swamps
giving last year cleaned up right on bro
oh we have a cigarette oh no no that
doesn't matter we don't need it well if
you don't want it I'll take it no no no
don't do that smoking is bad you should
quit smoking right now hey
great
[Music]
yeah they're caught on top of the fence
check out my calf it's like scratch City
ouch I'm fine
oh
my God it's gonna be fine
I still can't let you go to Florida
though Terry feels like a [ __ ] he said
if we disobey them they'll be tire
consequences I think he meant dire dire
yeah what's up squadron I'm airplane
ready and I'm T minus 30 from Miami's
kicking ends
let's take it to this guys yeah about
that how'd you take it before you're at
the airport yeah you got a long journey
ahead of you
the surgery and you just
you just okay we'll get you through this
oh what was that sound I did not like
that squish sound the pipe has been
removed tell me about Amy you must be
excited to see her very much you know oh
God what if it doesn't go well we
haven't seen each other in a while and
I'm sure it will be magical when you see
her and guess what what I'm done you're
efficient
huh you did great buddy I'm proud of you
I can't believe I did it
I'm so strong
[Laughter]
I need to go to the bathroom we just
stopped for gas I asked you if you had
to go I didn't have to then I had to pee
now too seriously
UDF look I'll turn off at the next exit
Okay I have to pee really badly
hot
oh
I agree
ow
wow audio transitions
the cops or Vegas do we have any weapons
I have the pipe we pulled out of me
oh [ __ ]
thank you guys so much for coming I
can't wait to catch up with all of you
when this is done and my dad died again
hahaha
Captain you stay here and rest what I
don't need to rest I'm in Peak condition
all right then stand up easy
I love sitting here
and I can stay here and take care of you
okay Terry I'm gonna need your gun
that's not happening dang I'll use my
own whoops a days
where did you get that vending machine
at a rest stop give me that
hahaha
oh my God everyone Jake and Amy are
going to kiss for the first time in six
months so
everyone's just gonna watch us yes
you love birds
here we go
hey there nikolaj it's your papa
something bad has happened to me but I
want you to know that I love you very
much you want to stop filming yourself
sorry I was making a video for my son
you know in case I never see him again
is he real do not do that for your kids
of course I do it's me Daddy if you're
seeing this I'm dead
but I want you to know that I love you
now and forever okay time for a lullaby
song in your native Latvian legal legal
yep go to sleep Daddy's dead but his
goals always won yes then Trevor sends
me a text and he's like at this point I
hate you I'm like oh really because you
didn't hate me last week Trevor sounds
like a dog right God I missed our daily
dishes I'm sorry I'm not reciprocating
with hot girls of my own I'm just
worried about the nine nine
you're my squad I should be there with
them
this is killing me
well I'm not gonna let it oh Sir with
your brain and my body and my brain we
make one Unstoppable unit now climb
aboard sir
and let's go
[Applause]
it's like there's no way
let's set this track
[Music]
hey you nailed it I'd love to kill you
tonight
it's where you hiding wouldn't you like
to know
you're never gonna find me I'm in I'm
invisible
that's good be a voice actor he's at the
Fun Zone gear up he knows exactly where
the fun zone is
who are you aiming for
[Laughter]
a better kisser than home what oh why
did I say that why did you kiss Holt I
didn't I did we did it to get out of
jail but it didn't mean anything just
forget I said anything right rewind
yes Jake you want to know if there was
time I can tell you decidedly there was
not no Jake Vegas is here
here we go excuse me ma'am this Dolly's
being used
it's being used
just bring it back when you're done
marinara Pizzeria
just when I was about to ask if that was
real Italian
jackpot let's do this and how am I
supposed to get all the way up there
just got the eyes
stick shift
me sir I will be your legs
okay
that's an experience I still need to
have in this life
nicely done you ruined my life
I had to live in Florida for six months
it's the worst have you tried the pizza
down here yeah it's the most disgusting
thing I've ever tasted it somehow burned
my mouth and is cold at the same time
[Laughter]
Floridians verifying the comments
we're gonna cuff everyone and then we're
gonna sort this all out
thank you yeah thanks Sheriff
oh yeah
non-lethal wound no one here really gets
shot in the show I'm gonna hold you
Hostage to get away then I'm gonna drive
to a gas station or I'll steal a clean
car then head for the airport where I'll
buy it take out my false ID then kill
you in a parking lot and disappear again
you're scrambling
[Laughter]
I'm gonna give you a window and you're
gonna go after Jake my name is detective
Rosa Diaz NYPD get back I'm reaching for
my badge
[Music]
it's a hell of a window to give yes give
everyone that gun down or he dies he's
not gonna shoot me he needs me alive to
get out of here yeah you willing to take
that bet I wouldn't
looks like your gun's aimed at him
shoot him shoot him into the chest
owie
that's what the nod meant it was it was
awesome it was actually just like the
end of speed which is a pretty good
movie it's not as good as I heard tires
she keep going after figure same page
still
get out of the car
oh yes I forgot about them
damn
freeze Punk yeah
lost and found at the storage facility
it boxes of them they're everywhere
yep
my fiance Adrian pimento said when I
caught you I should read you this letter
oh I want to lick the skin off your body
baby oh that side's for me
[Music]
[Laughter]
to say because I shot you but it feels
like we're back in sync now yeah I mean
as insane because I've ever been with
someone who just shot me and the frost
is very NSYNC
I love you
I love you too do it right here my blood
type yeah be positive
Mr Wrong hey Craig oh God
laughs
I know we disobeyed a direct order
Sergeant relax okay your friends were in
trouble you did what you had to do
and now I gotta do what I gotta do oh no
a memorandum of admonishment much worse
you're never gonna see the sun again
your families they're gonna forget your
faces you'll eat lunch at dinner time
and dinner at breakfast and you'll
I totally lost my train you were
punishing us yes thank you ah I'm
transferring the whole Squad to the
night shift no
no
yes not a doctor oh
we're back the show's good again it's
killing it took a while
according to Amazon this show is comedy
quirky strange and campy this has been
terrible lately yeah I hate finally got
good again every comedy because of how
bad this has been but now maybe my faith
can be restored that was hilarious
hilarious good time
um I thought Gina and Holt were yeah
this show is just not the same if
they're separated no they have to be
yeah Gina and Holt especially need to be
together to hold the b990 universe in in
order I mean I'm referring more yes that
but I also mean like the whole band
Squad yeah the band has to all be
together because like I'm like all right
this this Coral Palms Coral whatever
it's called it's finally it felt like it
was truly singing the most right now
because they're all together sure yeah
yeah and a very satisfying even though
you know the first part they're not in
it at all in the second part everyone is
separated but in the episode it feels
like a really nice progression to this
point so that it is actually cathartic
and rewarding and like a little bit fist
pumping when everybody finally yeah
comes back together I thought they took
down figures pretty fast
especially for a character who built up
for a very very long time it shows us
for one episode and they're like are we
gone yeah that's maybe my one complaint
is sort of like and I mean it seemed
like Eric Roberts showed up for it and
was game but yeah it's sort of like okay
we get this quick moment where he
Corners uh Jake and they have the whole
plan and then pretty soon it's all done
yeah wrapped up pretty quick and it
doesn't feel like it's gonna you know it
doesn't have any sort of thing to
suggest like well it's done for now but
he's gonna you know come back at some
point I'm sure he could but it doesn't
feel like yeah this is going to be be a
major flavor of the Season moving ahead
if they did like they did a whole
witness protection Arc here going
Witness Protection Program losing sight
of your own identity who are you really
and then trying to solve the case or
stuff getting caught the third episode
of fugitives having to clear your name
get help from some old Pals yeah it's a
good good fugitive arc on the runarch
this could have been a b99 movie almost
yeah and everyone was so funny in this
episode everyone had like a really good
moment to shine and I think uh Peralta
Amy
that's a nice realistic touch really
like how do you go back to flowing again
it could be weird yeah absolutely after
this extraordinary experience that is
also yet like for us to
you know we we haven't it's there was a
brief gap between season three and four
but you know we didn't wait either as
long as anybody who's watching live too
so I bet that felt a lot more
uh tangible the time that they've been
apart uh you know in the moment and yeah
like how would you just go back to
whatever your relationship was before
like there's so much to say but how do
you say it you know especially when
you're dealing with something like this
I feel like they shot the song
California
I'm not we could go to that convenience
store right now like it's it's like a
couple minutes yeah I think I know which
one you're talking yeah yeah uh yeah uh
there in fact there are a lot of places
that we could probably we really wanted
to do some kind of like tour of Brooklyn
Nine-Nine shooting locations we could
probably scrounge up like four or five I
mean it seems like they shoot it mainly
in New York actually
looks that way that's good I don't
believe they did all the street shots
they probably have a second unit out
there but there's a lot of stuff uh
that's downtown LA throughout the show
you think so at least when the actors
are there I don't know how funny I want
to say I I I run the streets a lot so I
constantly feel like yeah then again
when I don't want to call seeing too
many New York landmarks there's a lot
that looks like actual New York
I I mean I it's possible and I feel like
a show like this like not that they're
the same like when uh or Canada
who wants to get a lot of SNL alums too
yeah usually looks like they come down
the street yeah where do they shoot
Brooklyn Nine-Nine
season let's go season three
let's find out yeah
yeah shooting locations come on come
on come on everyone be quiet
we are doing research
there's got to be info
I doesn't say
I mean the show's done now so I guess I
feel like this information will be out
there I mean like like when my when my
dad found in Los Angeles you're right
that's the thing yeah it's like when my
dad used to work on CSI New York they
would be like once a season or something
like that they would go out and they
would do a big New York shoot of some
kind or like once in a while and then
they would have certain uh you know
second units out there to get their
establishing shots and stuff like that I
really thought they shot it in New York
oh yeah yeah like it is pretty
convincing and then occasionally there
will be an interior usually uh that that
is like oh that's right around here
that's in Burbank or something but I
think that a lot of the exteriors if you
go to downtown downtown where it is all
tall buildings and they're the
occasional one-way streets and stuff
like that I think that's where they do a
lot of the exteriors because there's
there's stuff that really looks like
those lots uh downtown that sort of are
littered between things like they do a
lot of shooting in those parking lots
that like charge for you know like
concerts at the Ace Hotel things like
that like mind blown right now in fact
like I don't know if this is true but I
feel like uh uh
uh the through a game of telephone I I
guess I'll say I feel like they wanted
to do more New York shoots or like a big
actual New York shoot and maybe didn't
get to but but that's a hearsay on my
part it might be harder to shoot actual
exterior locations in New York yeah
especially because whereas here it's
like it might be a hassle but at least
like that's what we're about so you know
someone will make it happen whereas like
I can't imagine having to shut down a
New York City street in Brooklyn uh part
of me is so surprised to learn that and
actually I think the only area of New
York
City I've been to is Brooklyn so maybe
that's it too I'm like
well regardless uh they did a refined
job here and everyone was hilarious once
again
and what more can you really say Scully
in Hitchcock man MVPs the episode killed
it this is just one so many important
one of the shows where we talk not much
after because you end up saying how
funny it is
and then going that moment that was
funny
yeah also funny
I maybe had a complaint about this but
most of all it was funny all right guys
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that Bell leave a like last but
not least and send with the patreon
so Gene Jeter Gene look Gene has an
awesome YouTube channel with a lot of
great things on there and he's got an
awesome Instagram with a lot of
beautiful people that he photographs
through and I'm never jealous no and I
wanted to do a theme shout out here I
typed in gene at NYPD officer Gene oh
yeah and uh it's nothing but just
terrible cops
two reports about either terrible
incidents happening to Cops named gene
or cops named Gene doing terrible stuff
I like they're so like the top one is
ex-officer who killed neighbor you're
like God like every one of these is so
bad you know what we should do here I
have an idea I have an idea let's do
jeans Florida man
have you done a Florida man have you
gotten a Florida man yet
I thought Florida bad okay
uh do you Florida man you search
typically you search your birthday along
with Florida man and then it'll give you
a news report from your birthday about
some floor you know the headlines
Florida man uh goes on a low-speed naked
go-kart Chase through a burrito Festival
you know like it's always some kind of
horrifically random thing and uh and
yeah it's a it's a meme
so uh how about how about this uh uh Hey
Abdul Jean Malik Florida man caught
alligator with trash can wins over the
Internet
so yeah this guy in Florida caught a
snake in a trap or an alligator in a
trash can and now he's a viral celebrity
and that could be you that could be your
Florida man Gene are there any other
ones I feel like names you would get a
lot more no it's just Gene Malik well
there you go it's perfect that's awesome
trap an alligator and and bring it to
Florida because if it's in New York it's
probably a Long Way from Home trap your
models and bring them to California
put them in a dumpster barrel and drag
them here push them all the way across
those City Limits push them across the
country all the way here Gene yeah
it's an all expenses paid trip
you know I think we nailed it Gene we
got creative just like there's another
one about a man accused of hitting a boy
in a stroller with a metal pipe Jesus
Gene Allen Florida man
no no we we had it before
[Music]